et l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de Madame Marie- Thérèse bruguère
à monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et la parole est à Monsieur
René Paul Savari en remplacement de
Madame bruguère
oui avec bien sûr toutes les excuses de
Madame bruguère retenu pour
convalissance suite à une intervention
chirurgicale mais tout se passe bien
soyez mes chers collègues rassurés
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale dans le contexte de la
discussion de sur la refondation de
l'école la question concerne
l'enseignement de la langue des signes
pour les enfants sourds après Étienne
deille en 1710 premier professeur sourd
à enseigner en langue des signes c'est
l'abbé de l'Épée qui ouvre en 1760 la
première école destinée aux jeunes sours
à Paris il instaure une véritable
éducation en langue des signes en
démontrant par la même l'importance de
constituer des groupes d'enfants sourds
pour le développement du langage de ces
10 enfants pour la première fois on
reconnaît que les gestes peuvent
exprimer la pensée humaine autant qu'une
langue orale la langue des signes va
s'imposer progressivement son Exor et
l'accès à l'enseignement permettent
alors au sour d'exercer de vrais métiers
et de se regrouper en association la
langue des signes est axée sur
l'appréhension visuelle et gestuelle du
monde les enfants sourds perçoivent avec
leurs yeux parlent avec leurs mains et
cela avec autant de richesse et de
facilité que le font les enfants
entendant s'exprimant dans une langue
vocale bien que la plupart des travaux
linguistiques sociologiques et
psychologiques démontre la nécessité
pour l'enfant d'accéder le plus tôt
possible à cette langue la quasittalité
des enfants sourds ne peut toujours pas
découvrir alors même qu' a très
largement été très largement prouvé
combien la pratique précoce de la langue
des signes favoriser le désir d'aller
vers d'autres formes langag orales ou
écrite la langue des signes françaises
est parfois présente dans les lieux
d'éducation ou de rééducation mais le
plus généralement de manière très
réduite certaines associations déplorent
aussi l'orientation éducative actuelle
visant à détruire les groupe d'enfants
sourds en les plaçant seul en
intégration dans leur école de quartier
cela conduit à la fois à isoler ses
enfants d'une relation enrichissante
avec leur père et a Ôé par la même la
vitalité de la langue des signe
françaises les spécialistes s'accordent
pourtant pour dire que si l'on veut que
les enfants sours accèdent au français
écrit dans toute sa richesse littéraire
il est indispensable de constituer des
groupes d'enfants signeurs parlant une
langue des signes de grande qualité et
en dépit de la législation existante le
constat est aujourd'hui encore
dramatique seulement 5 % des jeunes
sources sont ont accès à un dispositif
d'enseignement or la législation
française fav ant l'enseignement par
l'Éducation nationale de cette langue
existe mais souvre souffre d'un manque
d'application déjà depuis un certain
temps alors Monsieur le Ministre au-delà
des discours la législation actuelle en
matière de libre choix de communication
se révèle donc dans les faits
inégalitaires et discriminatoire puisque
ne mettant pas en place les véritables
conditions d'accès à cette langue pour
les familles et pour les enfants sours
eux-mêmes aussi Monsieur le Ministre
pouvez-vous nous indiquer à Marie
Thérèse bruguère et à moi-même quels
sont les projets du gouvernement sur
l'enseignement de la langue des signes
pour tous les enfants sourds et au-delà
pour les parents afin que ceux qui le
souhaitent puissent recevoir
gratuitement une formation en langue
d'essine française et enfin pour que les
enseignants sourds bénéficient d'un
véritable statut d'enseignant
correspondant à leur compétences je vous
remercie merci monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le sénateur Savari d'abord je
vous demanderai de bien vouloir
transmettre à à madame la sénatrice
bruguère tous mes vœux de pompe
rétablissement sur la question que vous
évoquez et avant d'en venir aux éléments
précis je voudrais vous
assurer de la conviction et de
l'engagement qui sont les miens sur ces
questions qui concernent l'école
inclusive il y a je l'entendais
récemment les disux et les faisux en
l'espace d'un an vous le savez la
priorité à l'école inclusive a été
fortement affirmé ou je dirais réaffirmé
car si même dans la loi de refondation à
laquelle vous avez
participé activement lors des débats
nous avons pour la première fois affirmé
l'école inclusive je reconnais que
l'idée en a été lancée par François
Fillon en 2005 à partir de 2010 notre
pays et je le redis n'a pas consacré à
ce projet d'une grande ampleur les
moyens nécessaires et après quelques
années d'effort a même détérioré
fortement la situation c'est pour cela
que dès notre arrivée au gouvernement
dans ce qui a été appelé le plan
d'urgence de la rentrée 2012 j'ai
souhaité le président de la République
et le Premier ministre ont accordé la
création en urgence de 1500 auxiliaires
de vie scolaire pour l'aide individuelle
et 2300 auxiliaires de vie scolaire pour
l'aide mutualisé vous savez que le 16
octobre dernier avec d'ailleurs des
impulsions fortes venues des chambres et
en particulier du Sénat madame George
Paul anevin ministre délégué à la
réussite éducative auprès de moi et
Madame Marie Arlette Carlotti Ministre
délégée chargée des personnes
handicapées et la lutte contre
l'exclusion ont installé sur ces
questions de pérénisation et de
formation des emploi c'est une question
majeure d'auxiliaire de vie scolaire un
groupe de travail dans la suite du
rapport de Madame comitÈ et que nous
cheminons vous le savez vers une
sédéisation de ces personnels qui était
tellement attendu depuis tant d'années
vous savez aussi que pour la rentrée
j'ai obtenu 10000 contrats aidés qui
pour la première fois vont de contrats
sur plusieurs années et vont être
accompagnés ce qui a toujours été un
problème majeur pour les uns et pour les
autres d'une véritable formation pour
accompagner les enfants en situation de
handicap vous savez aussi que dans les
cadres des écoles supérieures du
professorat et de l'éducation que nous
créons pour la rentrée j'ai demandé ça
n'a pas été d'ailleurs le plus simple
qu'un module de formation soit proposé à
tous les enseignants et tous les
personnels de l'Éducation nationale qui
intégreront ces écoles sur la prise en
charge des enfants en situation de
handicap dans leur classe notôre et ma
détermination est entière sur ce sujet
parce que je considère que c'est
vraiment le sujet on voit la différence
entre les paroles et les actes et où un
pays comme le nôtre peut sonoré j'espère
dans le consensus national du de progrès
et de prise en charge de ceux qui ont
besoin d'être intégrés et avoir accès
dans notre République à l'école dans le
rapport annexé suite aux propositions du
Sénat et en particulier relayé vous vous
en souvenez sans doute par la sénatrice
Dominique Gillot nous avons
modifié nos éléments juridiques et nous
avons précisé que les élèves sourds
auront accès à un parcours scolaire en
communication bilingue
enseignement en langue des signes et
langue françaisees ou en communication
en langue française enseignement en
français oral avec langage parlé
complété et français écrit pour cela des
dispositifs adaptés à cette
scolarisation seront développés par le
regroupement des élèves dans une même
classe ce qui répond à une partie de
votre question et de votre
interpellation ou la mutualisation des
moyens nécessaires dans un même
établissement à l'échelle académique la
logique n'est donc pas d'isoler ses
élèves mais au contraire de les
regrouper et leur donner les moyens nous
avons aujourd'hui 6000 à 7000 élèves qui
présentent des troubles de l'audition
des pôles pour l'accompagnement à la
scolarisation des jeunes sours que nous
appelons le vocabulaire passe ont été
créés en 2010 pour permettre à tous ces
élèves quel que soit le mode de
communication choisi par leur famille
c'est les familles évidemment qui
détermine ce mode de communication de
suivre un enseignement au plus près
possible c'est souvent la question d'une
scolarisation ordinaire sans se
focaliser sur la seule langue des signes
françaises les pas sont provocation
donné à chaque élève la possibilité de
choisir son mode de communication sans
qu'il y ait de hiérarchie entre l'ALSF
et ce qu'on appelle le langage parlé
complétés ces pôles sont actuellement
Monsieur le Sénateur madame la sénatrice
au nombre de 32 et ils sont articulés
autour d'un réseau de personnes
ressources constitué de médiateurs
pédagogiques qui sont choisis parmi les
professeurs du 1er ou du second degré
dans un rapport rendu en juillet 2012 et
que j'ai rendu public comme tous les
rapports de l'Inspection Générale
l'inspection générale de l'éducation
nationale a quand même mis l'accent sur
les difficultés réelles liées à la mise
en œuvre de ces dispositifs et en
particulier sur un problème qui nous
fait souci qui est que vous avez abordé
la mise en place de la ressource
enseignante capable de proposer ces
modes de communication j'ai donc
souhaité c'est la première limite à
laquelle nous nous heurtons aujourd'hui
j'ai donc souhaité que nous puissions
contourner cette difficulté structurelle
en étant capable de mobiliser et j'ai
demandé au service académique d'agir
dans cette direction les professionnels
et les associations de parents sourds
pour qu'on puisse mobiliser toutes les
compétences et pouvoir comme vous l'avez
souhaité à un moment les reconnaître
seul capable d'ailleurs parents
association de déterminer pour leurs
enfants quelles sont les meilleures
conditions de scolarisation j'encourage
donc nettement toutes les académies à
mutualiser aussi les moyens à leur
disposition afin de prendre en charge le
plus efficacement ses élèves ce c'est
devant nous un travail de longue haleine
car on a beaucoup d'étapes à franchir
elles sont d'ordre culturel elles sont
d'ordre matériel elles sont d'ordre de
la formation mais croyez que notre
détermination est entière et nous avons
déjà été accompagnés dans le Sénat dans
des premiers par le Sénat dans le
premers progrès et nous somes heureux de
poursuivre avec vous cette lutte qui est
importante merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le docteur
oui merci monsieur le ministre pour la
précision de votre réponse en 2è partie
de votre
intervention car en première partie vous
avez rappelé et fait la promotion de
votre loi sur la refondation ce que je
comprends bien volontiers effectivement
il y a depuis
1991 des lois qui permettaient
véritablement semble-t-il de prendre en
compte ce problème et en 2005 la loi sur
le handicap a permis effectivement de
donner des améliorations avec un
traitement bien spécifique pour les
handicaps sensoriels puisque c'est une
prestation de compensation forfaitaire
pour ces personnes en en situation de de
surdité qu'il y a là un moyen de faire
peut-être avancer les choses il
n'empêche qu'il semblerait que dès
1998 un rapport sur le droit des sours
et est montrer qu'il y avait encore un
un un étrisme très important parmi ces
personnes sourdes c'est la raison pour
laquelle faut véritablement s'atteler à
ce problème et j'ai cru comprendre votre
détermination à travers de votre réponse
et au nom de Madame Brugière je vous en
remercie